Hey guys,
You know, I'm on my way to the gym.
And I realized that I haven't
been to the gym in almost a month.
That's just how busy we are here at DLM.
My team and I are working crazy early
mornings - late nights - and trying to get videos
out there to share the gospel on Men's Lifestyle
and Christian Lifestyle every week.
And it's been difficult.
We have load shedding here in South Africa.
Scheduled power outages, which makes things worse.
And thank you Liz and Ross from our DLM
family for buying for us a generator
for me and for Danie and Jaques, the
team manager and the head video editor.
They bought them inverters, which is amazing, so
the three of us can power through power outages.
But I want to ask you guys to please continue
to pray for us and support us as a team.
I love you guys and thank you.